seit ich eigentlich
meine eltern eigentlich oder familie
vermisst haben wird ich habe immer
gesagt eines tages werden sie suchen
gehen und bis jetzt kein erfolgreicher
muss ich selber und es hat sich aber
wirklich so ergeben dass ich jetzt diese
treffen wird innenstadt bin dass ich
schon seit 32 jahren
wahnsinn
red ist etwa acht jahre alt als er von
den roten khmer entführt wird
er konnte keine ziehung lager wurde das
kämpfen lernen muss red wird ein
kindersoldat zu diesem zeitpunkt glaubte
nicht mehr daran seine eltern jemals
lebend wiederzusehen
heute ist dieser tag gekommen
was bedeutet heimat für einen mann der
über 30 jahre nicht zu hause war
davon handelt diese geschichte
und wir nicht kennen
[Musik]
es blühen
das bmx
[Musik]
drei wochen vor unserer reise chef red
und seine frau anita an ihrem wohnort in
nied wenigen im kanton bern
vor elf jahren hat red die bauerntochter
aus dem emmental kennen und lieben
gelernt
[Musik]
auf ersten blick so sie kommen so was
ist das für ein händler
wie schon immer mein vergangene volk
beziehung sind irgendwie alle frauen für
blond gewesen wenn ich so überdauern
keine jahr 2007 heiraten die beiden uns
als wäre die liebesgeschichten nicht
schon perfekt wird in wenigen wochen
noch ein weiterer höhepunkt folgen
[Musik]
das match wird immer stärker was es
heißt bald vater zu werden
und genau in diese zeit kommt unerwartet
der anruf aus kambodscha seine eltern
leben telefon ich wusste nicht was ich
sagen soll
ich habe erst hallo mutter habe ich
immer erst mal gesagt ja mehr habe ich
nicht es gibt ja und das ist schon
wahnsinnig ich kann euch das ja fast gar
nicht so das ist wirklich alles auf
einmal der ganze 30 jahre hat sich
aufgestaut auf dieser moment oder vor 30
jahren ist red vor dem krieg geflüchtet
monate lang lebte allein auf der straße
bis in das rote kreuz aufgreift
er ist eines von 107 kambodschanischen
kindern die nach deutschland gebracht
werden
red und seine adoptiv blut pauli finden
in tübingen eine neue familie schnell
ein jet deutsch vergisst ein
kambodschanisch und versenkt den krieg
weil er niemand hungern will wird koch
sein beruf bringt ihn schließlich in die
schweiz und zu anita seriös quelle das
ist eben das thema krieg ist ja die
familie wacker sind die wurzeln finden
und ich danke ich sehr sehr wichtig dass
sie zu bekommen auch das ist ja immer
vor sich hergeschoben und jetzt die
saubere familie und beißkorb habe ich
sag mal ich gehe nicht nach hause
sondern ich begegne ein wurzel wieder
das bedeutet für mich es kann dann
wieder ein 1 1 1 1 zu hause sein vom
frühjahr das wird es wird so ähnliches
sein aber ich kann mir das nicht sagen
dezember 2008 im neuen jahr wird es nach
kambodscha fliegen allein wie die reise
in seine ursprüngliche heimat die
beziehung verändert könnte beschäftigt
anita welcher dieses buch ja unbedingt
[Musik]
und dann ist da der januar am flughafen
widget von seinem freund kommen abgeholt
auch kommen weil eines der 107
flüchtlingskinder die 1979 nach
deutschland kamen
er hat seine familie bereits vor vielen
jahren wiedergefunden kennt kultur und
sprache seines landes er weiß welche
probleme fred zukommen könnten
sie werden was eine immer daran denken
dass da hinten ein reicher mann ist weil
er von von europa kommt das habe immer
gesagt also wenn du flugticket sagen
kannst dann bist du auch reiche also
eine art und weise und es wird immer in
frage kommt kannst du mir dort helfen
jenes helfen oder viele verschulden sich
irgendwo damit musste ich ja immer
einspringen und das muss er entscheiden
ob er das machen will und nicht und ich
von meiner seite ab in den rat gegeben
dass er genau überlegen soll was er
unterschied zwischen wichtig und nicht
wichtig machen und unter den augen
sprechen zu helfen damit die familie
kein fest organisiert und sich dafür
gern verschuldet haben komm und red
beschlossen den eltern nicht zu sagen
dass sie schon hier ist mit spannung und
auch mit furcht muss ich dazu sagen weil
ich kenne sie wirklich nicht ich habe
überhaupt keine erinnerung mehr an ihn
an sie allgemein
[Musik]
von phnom penh ins dorf rad fahren wir
über drei stunden jede kilometer bringt
neue erinnerungen aus dieser grüne
professor länglich sie das hier
wir haben als junge stock geworfen hatte
ich so herunterhängen
und anderes geht vergessen
hey hallo machte sorgen oder was
a
fünf uhr habe ich gar nicht vor lauter
viel druck haben und unser nachwuchs ein
bisschen vergessen das tut mir leid gab
aber wie geht's mir geht unser baby
beginnt unser baby
ja ich vermisse das ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
gerade hat
[Musik]
ein
von monaco nicht nur die mutter und der
vater sehen sind noch am leben
es sind über 30 familienmitglieder die
retter findet und immer mehr kommen
hinzu es ist meine familie erst genau so
aus wie ich weiß ja wo mein kleiner
bruder sieht auch was aus wie ich und
meine geschwister wie man sieht ich
denke mal das ist wirklich meine familie
aber 100 prozentig am anfang hatten wir
keine hoffnung mehr dass unsere zwei
vermissten söhnen aufleben wir konnten
sie nicht finden
wir gingen zu einem wahrsager und meinte
ein sohn wäre noch am leben
das freut uns und wir schöpfen wieder
hoffnung
[Musik]
und woran hat sie erkannt
red will erfahren wie seine familie lebt
seine schwester navi zeigt ihr haus und
führt den koch als erstes in die küche
[Musik]
hast du hier kenne ich natürlich nicht
gerade aber ja das ist die traditionelle
fisch fermentierter fisch da stellt sich
barock und die tun sie quasi hier eine
gehackte sind hackfleisch und so sowieso
so herzustellen dass ich wirklich ein
quasi bei uns wie eine gleiche satz
fleischgeschmack ersatz
und das ist wirklich stinkt erbärmlich
aber so wie bei unserer käse auch aber
es schmeckt
ja das ist aber nicht so wachse hier ist
ja ihr trinkwasser und zusätzlich nehmen
sie auch zum zum waschen und zum so
baten über für mich also das ist ja so
dass man das wasser trinken kann das ist
jetzt für mich unvorstellbar nun auch
nicht mal ich würde nicht mal im bad
nehmen und ich machte meine kleider
waschen würde ich nehmen und das ist
halt schon lieber hier im land so und
das ist das ganze über die ganze
familien die ich das ist ihre
wasserstelle ohne wasser aus dem hahn
und körper ja
was wäre wenn er das kind nicht entführt
worden wäre hätte erhält endlich die
antwort einen einblick in das leben
das seien es hätte sein können und das
leben seiner brüder
ich fühle mich sehr wohl
und 2 ich hätte gern ein bisschen mehr
herzlichkeit war dieser dieser respekt
schwelle habe mir viel zu viel ja ich
mich gern mit ihnen lieber herumtollen
und irgendwas blödsinnig machen aber das
gilt anscheinend nicht nein
ja ja ich kann jetzt moment ich muss
noch die länge hat noch nicht gestimmt
ich schneide viel zu lang von verhalten
haben ein paar an das heißt europäer
oder franzose es gibt ja so und das habe
ich ja so manch anderer gehört oder ja
ich sei ein er ist eine europäer
[Musik]
die familie hat für red nun doch ein
grosses fest organisiert und das ganze
dorf dazu eingeladen zu der zeremonie
gehört auch das verteilen von geschenken
und geld diese rolle versucht die red
eigentlich zu vermeiden nun hatte keine
wahl
[Musik]
vor vielen jahren wurde eine totenfeier
führt durchgeführt diese gilt es nun
aufzuheben
red sind alle rituale fremd er ist auf
die hilfe seines bruders angewiesen
nach der zeremonie wissen die ahnen dass
red am leben ist und nun wieder zur
familie gehört
manche
einmal vorher war echt nicht komplett
ich bin immer auf der suche immer in
meinen gedanken ist ja ok es lebt
irgendwo noch mal eine familie und das
ist der druck ist weg und jetzt kann ich
mit ganz andere auch mit ganz anderer
art mein leben weiter zu machen und zwar
stressfrei und friedlicher also ich bin
wirklich nimmer dieser krise dieser auf
der suche
sondern ich bin jetzt irgendwo
angekommen red wird längerem kambodscha
bleiben er hat sich viel vorgenommen
möchte einen brunnen bauen und das haus
seiner schwester in stand setzen
zwei monate nach unserem besuch steht
drehen
der vater von red fast gleichzeitig
erhält die mit wenigen ein kleiner junge
seinen namen 15 jahren heute besuche ich
die familie geld noch einmal die gerber
sind in der schweiz geblieben die
kambodschanische kultur ist aber ein
fester teil ihres lebens geworden nun
eigentlich jetzt fünfmal jedes jahr sind
die jungen hätten aus dem rucksack und
andere land 100ste in gebäuden auf dem
traumschiff brachte das ist das thema
die familie ist mitglied im
buddhistischen quer verein des kantons
bern im gemeindesaal von barry wird
heute das kambodschanische neujahrsfest
gefeiert und auf wehen wartet jemand
ganz besonderes sein götti com
[Musik]
ich habe den eindruck mit fühlt sich
mittlerweile in der kambodschanischen
kultur und mentalität sehr viel wohler
was bringt es hat sich aber auch
bestätigt dass von rückkehrer viel
erwartet wird noch immer unterstützte
seine familie in kambodscha finanziell
blut ist dicker als wasser oder das ist
halt schon so man verpflichtet sich zu
auch schon gewisse fragen zu helfen
und da ist der zweitälteste bin ich bin
quasi so ja fast familienoberhaupt schon
angesehen dort und das bin ich
eigentlich gar nicht hat seine wurzeln
in der heimat wieder gefunden aber für
ihn besteht kein zweifel mehr ruhe zu
hause ist wenn ich vom familie redet
dann ist meine familie
was ich hier bekommen habe was ich hier
ja ich habe mir einen kleinen sohn und
das ist mein sagen meine familie mich
hier sagen kann mit stolz meine familie
[Musik]